في تكساس
هذا الصيف أثناء قراءة روديو
ثور أفلت من الحلبة قفز
إلى المدرجات ، كنت جالسًا في
ذلك المقعد الركني هناك
، أصاب ستة أشخاص بجروح ،
أحدهم بايج كينغ البالغ من العمر 25 عامًا أرسلها
إلى المستشفى.  يعني أنني نزلت
ولم أكن أعرف حقًا ما
الذي كان يحدث بالضبط ، استغرق الأمر مني ثانية
، ثم اصطحبني صديقي
وأصبحت وكأن هناك
وعاءًا هناك مخيفًا
لعائلة Pages بما في ذلك والدها  لأن
الثور قد قفز من السياج والحمد لله
خرج الثور للتو
من البوابة ولكن في تحول خارق
للأحداث ، كشف علاج إصاباتها
عن أن بايج تعاني من أزمة صحية
باقية في الداخل ، نريد أن
نذهب إلى غرفة الطوارئ ومن خلالها
أنهم قاموا بفحصها بالأشعة المقطعية
وثانوية لأي إصابات داخلية
لاحظوا وجود ورم في رقبتها في
غرفة الطوارئ قال الطبيب أنه يجب
عليك فحص ذلك وسيتم
اكتشاف ذلك  كانت Paige في
المراحل الأولى من إجابة سرطان الغدة الدرقية ، لقد
صُدمت بالفعل بكل صدق حيث
اكتشف أحد أطفالك أنهم قد
يكونون مصابين بالسرطان ، فهذا نوع
ما يعيدك ويعطيك قشعريرة بعد أن
ظهر السرطان في الضوء سمع مذيع أمريكي في مسابقة روديو
قصتها المؤيدة لمسابقة روديو Hall
of Famer ، أخبر بوب تالمان الأسرة إذا
كان السرطان قد أرسلها إلى منشأة علاجية
في تكساس حيث يمكنها الحصول على
رعاية متخصصة بعد
أن اتصلنا ببوب قبل أسبوعين
وقال هنا اتصل بهذا الطبيب بشكل صحيح
هم الآن في هيوستن بولاية
تكساس وسيهتمون بك ، لقد أوضحنا
الموقف وقالت إنك بحاجة إلى القدوم
إلى هنا وهناك مركز للسرطان في
هيوستن يُدعى مركز إم دي أندرسون للسرطان ،
إنه الأفضل في البلاد ، وقالت إن
هذا هو المكان المناسب لك  بحاجة إلى الحصول على علاج
بعد صفحة المحنة ، كانت منظف منزل
في طريقها إلى منزل أحد العملاء
وكان المنزل يحتوي على ثيران على أرضهم
كنت أقود السيارة ونظرت إلى
يساري وفجأة رأيت هذه الكرة و
إنه يبدو متطابقًا معه ونظرت إلى
زميلتي في العمل ، وأعتقد أنه لا توجد
طريقة نعم ، حيث كان الثور بايج قد التقط
اللحظة المذهلة على كاميرا ذلك
الحيوان التي أنقذت حياتها في النهاية ، لقد
كانت لحظة دائرة كاملة في بلدي.  الحياة
ونعم سأعتز بها إلى الأبد ظل براون
أخبار الولايات الشمالية